je m'appelle ancenis marie paule et je
suis confuse à domicile depuis le mois
de janvier
2014 donc en fait aujourd'hui je venu
présenter mon projet de catalogue de
coiffure j'aimerais en fait créé le tout
premier coiffe catalogue de coiffure de
la réunion depuis que je suis coiffeuse
à domicile
souvent on voit des catalogues de
coiffure qui correspondent pas du tout
aux types de cheveux de la réunion
cheveux réunionnais métissée donc voilà
le genre de catalogue qu'on trouve en
fait
dans tous les salons de l'île de la
réunion sachant qu'ici aujourd'hui nous
sommes quand même une population assez
métissée donc ce genre de catalogue de
coiffure ne correspond pas du tout à la
clientèle réunionnaise j'ai l'intention
de créer un catalogue de coiffure pour
l'océan indien pour la réunion pour
l'océan indien maurice madagascar et
tout ce qui comprend laisse l'océan
indien donc aujourd'hui voilà le projet
que je présente au challenge des
créateurs